foreign
Jessica is in Michigan hi Jessica what's
up
seven years old and I'm a single mom of
two and
um my question is is how do I
um get the momentum to
um I'm on beta stuff number one I am
about uh 30 or I'm sorry seventeen
thousand dollars in debt between student
loans
um no my card's completely paid off but
I'm just trying to get momentum into
getting that cash shaved up for a baby
step number one because I always try to
validate my purchases
and I'm just trying to find a way to get
the momentum to stop validating
um right now I make about a little over
38 a year okay all right what has caused
you to want to do this plan in the first
place
11 years but I've already jumped into it
more in the last couple of months um
wanting to say it was going to change my
family tree I come from a family where
where we've all not been so great with
money and um my dad actually died I'll
tell you how I did it Jessica as a
fellow Spender
yeah I looked at my kids they were
babies and we were broke because of my
stupidity
and I said I'm not doing this anymore
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired and every time I got ready to
spend
I treat I would ask myself if I had to
not spend this money so that I had the
money to save the life of my child could
I do it could I find the discipline and
that was an easy answer of course and so
I did stuff like I would practice going
to Costco and buying nothing and walking
out
and that was like a breakthrough for me
because I truly thought that if you went
to Sam's or Costco that they check your
your receipt on the way out to that it
was federal law that you had to spend
200 or you couldn't get out they
wouldn't let you out that's why they
check it and um I was that guy and and
so I just had to I kind of had to equate
it with the life of my children which is
a bit melodramatic but it's also kind of
true because you want to change your
family tree you said yeah what does 40
year old Jessica want to look back on
and say man I'm so glad Jessica made
those decisions and if that means you
know taking away your debit card
information from every website that you
have hiding it having accountability
with a friend do whatever it takes I
would think if you've got a spending
problem that Amazon Prime is not even a
possibility I'm cutting that out of my
life it's Gotta you got to turn it off
if you got a spending problem if you're
trying to say no I'm not going to spin
because I mean that's just so easy it's
easy for me you know and I teach this
stuff for a living so you just gotta you
gotta equate it with a big why
and you got to be sick and tired of
being sick and tired and then gradually
you'll reform your character